hello everyone and welcome back to the
Capablanca saga we are back at the 1918
tournament of New York where cover Lanka
faces his old rival David Janoski and
it's again from round six cup of bunker
skipped again from round five as there's
an odd number of players in the
tournament you already talked about that
and part of this game Blanka faced young
offski seven times and out of those
seven times capablanca won six games and
only lost one to 2013 one that was
played in in in Cuba Havana so
definitely he has hit the score going
for him six to one and now he gets the
white pieces against Janos but he will
also face him again as it's a double
round-robin so an Oscar will also have
the white pieces once in this tournament
without further ado kappa blanka still
without loss in this tournament he opens
with d4 and as you can see d4 is already
on the board with d5 Knight to f3 Knight
to f6 c4 and of course you all know the
blacks next move we have E six and we
have the Queens gambit declined on the
board Bishop to g5 by Capablanca 9b d7
with III and now Knight sorry c6 and
Knight B to d2 preparing to capture on
c4 with the night after the bishop is
developed so a bit of a different setup
then and then by the going into normal
Knight to c3 idea Bishop to e7 now
capablanca goes Bishop to d3 and Janoski
captures and c4 after the Bishop has
been developed as it is customary in the
Queens gambit the client but now
capablanca doesn't capture with the
bishop as here black could have the
option of just maybe trading some pieces
after 95 captures captures and it would
be easier for black to play this game so
Capablanca captures would the Knight as
he did prepare this move and as you can
see also the knight is eyeing this very
nice d6 square which Capablanca will is
hoping to use later
we have castles by black castles by
Capablanca and now we have the early c5
there is no time for b6 if you go b6
first preparing Bishop to b7 then come a
bunker can take this opportunity as the
c6 pawn is a target you can go Knight f
e5 attack the pawn and after Bishop e7
just Queen to f3
and you will not be able to go c5
because the bishop on b7 is unguarded so
here you would go into something like
Knight captures Knight captures on e5
and now Knights the d5 just blocking
well a Knights attack towards the the c6
pawn Knight here then comes Queen to h3
threatening checkmate and here after f5
blocking you would get this well a very
very interesting position where after
captures and capture through kd1 it's a
it's a very nice position but the white
is still better black still has to
figure out how to activate the bishop on
b7 White has a monster knight on e5 g4
is still the idea where black will not
be able to capture due to the obvious
threat of checkmate so that's why an
auskey goes with the c5 immediately and
now the phone is no longer on c6 couple
luck will not be able to use it as a
target and now b6 is the idea we've
roped to c1 and now comes to b6 and
Queen to e2 by capablanca Bishop to b7
now an auskey has a monster bishop if
you will
rook F the d1 just developing the rook
lining and up nicely with the Queen on
the D file and now comes Knight to d5
hoping to trade bishops here and here a
couple longer goes Knight to d6 it's a
very nice move of course the bishop
cannot capture as Bishop captures Queen
would happen and on the other hand and
Knight still threatens to capture the
bishop on b7 so Bishop to see sexy on
offski does not allow this trade
we have Knight back to e4 kappa blanka
now just riemann over the knight from c4
to e4 and now both Knights are defending
the bishop here and g5 and here again
it's it's a very rich position Black has
a lot of options here but again you have
to be careful for example if you go for
a normal-looking move like let's say
Knight f6 just you know bringing the
pieces where they should be then couple
Blanca can go Knight e5 now use this
this Bishop on c6 as a target to improve
the position of his night and after
Bishop to b7 now you get Knight captures
Bishop captures Bishop Beatrice and now
the Queen cannot capture if you capture
over the Queen night here would win the
exchange so you'd have to go Knight
captures and
now D captures and c5 wins the game for
white it's it's that simple because
virtual captures on h7 is the threat you
would win the Queen here so black would
have to react to this if you go Knight
here then you leave the Queen side a bit
the King side a bit defenseless
you'd have to block with the bugger
should be fine and then just c6 you
create a passed pawn and that passed
pawn well we knew the game eventually
let's say Queen c7 blocking attacking
the knight just f4 cementing that knight
on e5 you have the beautiful c6 passed
pawn and white will be winning this
position so although it's a very rich
position you don't you can to just play
anything so here we have f5 and it's a
very nice idea by offski because it
forces kappa blanka to decide what to do
with the knight and also even though for
the moment it leaves the e6 pawn weak
Capablanca is preparing sorry a Janoski
is preparing to push it to e5 once the
trade on e7 happens so we have Bishop
captures Queen captures Knight goes back
to d2 and now not allowing this pawn to
remain here as a weakness just pushing
it to e5 and getting rid of it D
captures on e5 by kappa blanka we have
Knight captures on e5 Knight captures
Queen captures and now just Knight to f3
kicking the Queen back and Queen to e7
so it seems that your norske solved all
of his problems his knight is on an
excellent d5 squared the bishop still
alive assuming the excellent diagonal
the rook still needs to be developed the
end of skew will figure out what to do
with it but here kappa blanka plays a
move that most likely either Janoski
missed or he just couldn't find a better
continuation even while this move is
here here capablanca goes night to d4
he's hoping to get rid of Janoski strong
disappear by pawn captures and rook
captures here on c6 and this indeed
happened in the game and now you know
she has to figure out what to do here
and it is the best choice for black if
you just move it back then you lose the
f5 pawn that's not really something you
want to do and if you try something like
Bishop to d7 just the guarding that f5
pondan Bishop to c4 will be deadly and
there's not all that much you can do
here
if see captors on d4
of capture Sun d5 this comes with check
and after King to h8 now just bushel
captures rook and it's winning for white
so after this night to be for movie
enough she decided to capture it we have
pawn captures rook captures and c6 and
now again you have to decide what to do
Bishop to c4 a very strong threat for
example if you continue D captures on e3
which seems reasonable as the knight and
queen are both guarding the e3 square
again this Bishop to c4 move is very
problematic for black noble the bishop
and the rook or attacking the knight and
let's say pawn captures on f2 King
captures you're still gonna lose the
night like the Queen h4 checking return
0k8 just rook the e6 now even this is
possible rook captures Bishop captures
on d5 and black will always be down a
piece King h8 you can just capture here
and white is up the beasts and of course
completely winning Black has no counter
play
so after this rook captures on c6 move
we have Knights the B for attacking the
rook and the bishop on d3 and offski
hopes cover Blanca will move the rook so
he can get rid of the strong leadership
and d3 but Capablanca says no way thank
you for the e6 square he just delivers
Czech Bishop to c4 check King has to
move and now rook to e6 and now if you
just move the Queen then rook captures
on d4 will be very strong so here you
know ski try is a tricky idea pawn to d3
now of course you can either capture
with the bishop but then your rook will
no longer be guarded you can't capture
with the Queen because the night also
guards the pawn so here comes rook
captures on d3
yanovskiy is not in time to capture the
rook here so Queen to c5 has to be
played and now Capablanca just goes rook
to d4
I'm just getting drunk out of harm's way
and also rook to h4 will be a very nice
rook lift so b5 attacking the bishop and
here kappa blanka calculates precisely
he plays a bishop capture son b5 he just
grabs a pawn black it doesn't have a
good reply to this but there was an even
better move but feel free to pause the
video and try to find it this better
move a couple Blanca was too lazy to
calculate I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are in
excellent sacrificer of Bishops and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
the idea is Queen to h5 and now it's
just a big position
improver rope to h4 is coming and
there's not all that much you can do to
stop rock h4 even if you capture the
bishop it doesn't help you
rook h4 still wins the game and now you
have to prevent checkmate somehow you
can go h6 but just real captures and now
whatever black plays if king g8 rocket
rate is checkmate the Queen is
controlling the f7 square or if you
capture Geoff's Queen captures King g8
and Queen g6 will be checkmate Queen
controls f7 and the rope controls the h5
so after this b5 move capablanca most
likely again he saw this was winning so
he probably was lazy to calculate Queen
H what he just grabs a pawn
we have Knight captures an a2 now comes
Bishop back to C for attacking the
knight Knight to b4 and now when there
is no danger workup of lanka doesn't
have to calculate whether or not to
sacrifice the bishop now he goes Queen
to h5 and it's basically the same idea
but it was way cooler to do it when his
bishop was under attack
we have g6 by black but it doesn't help
couple Blanca just plays rook captures
and g6 as of course the bomb cannot
capture we have rook 8 to be 8 and here
capablanca finds that brilliant move but
again I will let you just and to find
the smooth feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out the easiest way to
win this position with white and it is
the move Capablanca played I'll give you
a couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations who
are also an excellent sacrificer of
rooks and for those who just want to
enjoy the show rook to g7 this was the
move kappa blanka played and it was in
his position
unmoved 30 that David Janoski resigns
the game as there is nothing to do here
well obviously the threat is Queen
captures on h7 this will be checkmate so
you do have to do something about it
obviously you can capture the rook it's
the only possible defense but after we
capture the rook now you get the
following sequence which of course you
all saw Queen g5 check the Queen covers
there 6 the bishop well not that the
Queen covers f6 before
covers this diagonal so the king would
have to go back and now comes rope
captors on d8 and there is no defense
against checkmate that follows for
example if you capture just Queen to f6
this is checkmate as special controls g8
square if you don't capture it if you
play something silly let's say knight c6
again you get Queen to f6 checkmate the
rook cannot capture as the rook is
pinned and even with the best defense
let's say Knight d5 just putting a
knight there I mean there's no good
reason to do it but you are controlling
the f6 squared with the night so there's
no checkmate white can just go rogue d7
threatened checkmate on g7 after rogue
g8 blocking
now Queen to h4 threatening checkmate
again also defending the bishop on c4
and after black blocks again would rock
the g7 just real captures on d5 when the
piece attacks the Queen and after the
Queen moves well it will again all
result in checkmate whatever you do I
say you just move the Queen back doesn't
really help you Ruby d8 check Anna
doesn't matter what you do captures
captures rule g8 and of course Queen
captures and g8 will again be checkmate
so Janoski did not wait for all any of
this after Luke g7 he resigned the game
and we have this beautiful beautiful
game by Jose rule kappa blanka still
undefeated in this tournament and well
he's really having an excellent streak
ever since he was 2 Oscar highs in the
1916 rising a Memorial Tournament I know
I often repeat that but you know you you
do want to remember it for when you're
you know
yeah chilling with your friends and
family so you can tell them all about a
couple of Uncas great a legendary
winning streak so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank David galleon Dhammapada it's
Christopher brown Francois Xavier
ferritin and Joseph Bru Lawrence for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content nearing
the Koppelman kisara change governor of
suggestions and the Grantchester starts
today so if I will be able to I will
also cover some games from the
Grantchester
thank you all I will soon have an
excellent rest of your day